Sir Winston Churchill: The Indispensable Lion
We imagine Winston Churchill with his signature
cane, drinking scotch whiskey, and puffing
on a Cuban cigar.
His mouth is downturned, and his voice is
gruff and his words pointed.
This is the image Hollywood portrays but it
is a mere caricature of the flesh and blood
version.
Who was Winston Churchill?
In Britain’s “darkest hour,” Churchill
led his country from the brink of Nazi conquest
by forging an alliance with the U.S. and Russia.
He had many critics, and made mistakes on
a grand scale.
Yet, above it all, possessed an unwavering
belief in his own power.
To his beloved country he offered his “blood,
toil, tears and sweat.”
Behind the political figure was a family man,
a man of literary distinction, an artist,
a great lover of pets, and a tinker -- he
had many hobbies.
Today on Biographics we paint the complex
picture of “The Lion,” Sir Winston Churchill.
Formative Years
Sir Winston Churchill was born on November
30, 1874 into the upper echelons of British
society.
His father was Lord Randolph Henry Spencer-Churchill,
a prominent politician and the third son of
the of the seventh Duke of Marlborough.
Churchill’s mother, Jennie Jerome, was an
American beauty and socialite, the daughter
of a wealthy New York stock broker and financier.
The glamorous couple would seem like a match
made in heaven but they lived mostly apart
and carried on separate lives.
They also couldn’t be bothered with the
young Winston; the very privilege of his pedigree
didn’t afford him the kind of love and affection
he sought from his parents.
Sadly, throughout his life, both father and
mother were distant and neglectful.
Fortunately for the young Winston, there was
one adult in his life who provided emotional
support and acted like a mother figure — Churchill’s
nanny, Elizabeth Everest.
“Woom,” he called her after a failed attempt
at saying woman as a child, was hired to care
for Winston when he was one month old.
She would remain his only real friend and
confidante throughout his childhood.
When she passed away, Churchill said of her,
"She had been my dearest and most intimate
friend during the whole twenty years I had
lived.
I shall never know such a friend again."
Winston was just seven years old when he was
sent away to St. George’s School at Ascot,
a boarding school.
It was not uncommon for schoolchildren in
upper-class society to be sent away, but his
mother dropped him off at Paddington Station
alone to catch the train.
At his first school, Winston was bullied and
bruised by the headmaster who commonly “birched”
the students, a form of corporal punishment
that involved striking the bare bottoms of
boys that misbehaved.
With visible scars on Winston from the beatings,
and pleas from his loving nanny, his parents
withdrew him and placed him at Brighton School
in 1882.
Winston escaped the brutality of his first
school but not the lessons at Brighton, which
he despised.
Winston hated the regiment and was rebellious;
his poor academic scores and speech impediment,
a lisp, made Winston an easy target and subject
to ridicule.
In 1888, Winston enrolled at the Harrow School
but with abysmal entry scores, he placed at
the bottom of his class.
At Harrow, Winston excelled only in the subjects
that interested him, including English and
history.
He demonstrated a prowess for the sport of
fencing, winning the Public Schools’ fencing
championship.
Yet, the few bright spots were overshadowed
by deep sadness.
Winston recalled, “... In retrospect those
years form not only the least agreeable, but
also the only barren and unhappy period of
my life."
Winston Churchill nearly died from a self-imposed
act of bravado at the age of 18 when he jumped
off a bridge.
He would endure three days of unconsciousness,
a ruptured kidney, and three months in bed.
It happened when the teenager was playing
chase with his 12-year old brother Jack and
14-year old cousin while vacationing at their
aunt’s estate.
According to Churchill in his 1930 memoir,
he was “trapped” on a “rustic bridge”
with brother at one end and cousin at the
other.
Rather than be “captured,” Churchill lept
from the bridge, aiming for a pine tree to
slide down.
He greatly misjudged the distance and fell
the full height onto the hard ground.
Churchill was extremely lucky to survive but
it wouldn’t be his last brush with death.
During his life Churchill was prone to accidents,
including crashing a plane while learning
to fly, nearly drowning in a lake, falling
several times from horses, and getting hit
by a car while trying to cross New York’s
Fifth Avenue.
Military Service & War Correspondent
Due to his poor grades at Harrow, it appeared
Churchill’s only chance at a career was
through the army.
It took Churchill three tries to pass the
admittance exam for the Royal Military College
at Sandhurst.
Churchill described taking the Latin portion
of the exam and leaving it completely blank
except for his name, a number, and “a blot
and several smudges.”
His father had wanted him to be in the Infantry
but his scores were only good enough for the
Cavalry.
The new training at Sandhurst excited Churchill
and over the next 18 months Churchill thrived.
He recalled, "I was no longer handicapped
by past neglect of Latin, French or Mathematics.
We had now to learn fresh things and we all
started equal.
Tactics, Fortification, Topography [mapmaking],
Military Law and Military Fortification, formed
the whole curriculum.
In addition were Drill, Gymnastics and Riding."
Churchill finished twentieth out of 130 in
his graduating class.
Churchill craved action and showed no fear
on the battlefront.
He knew he was destined for great things and
would prove it to the world...war provided
the perfect opportunity.
Churchill served in the British Army for only
a short time, from 1895 to 1899, and during
the same time wrote military reports for newspapers
and two books, The Story of the Malakand Field
Force and The River War.
In 1899, Churchill tried to win election in
the House of Commons and failed.
Without hesitation, he traveled to South Africa
to cover Britain’s war with the Boers as
a London Post war correspondent.
At the age of 25, Churchill arrived in Cape
Town with 18 bottles of scotch whiskey and
a guarantee of $150,000 in today’s money,
for a four-month assignment.
One day, Churchill admitted to his brother,
“There is no ambition I cherish so keenly
as to gain a reputation for personal courage.”
He would soon get the chance to earn that
reputation in South Africa.
While covering the war, Churchill was aboard
a train with soldiers sent on a reconnaissance
mission.
The train was suddenly ambushed by the enemy
and Churchill immediately sprung into action.
Under fire, he acted like a decorated general
and ordered the soldiers with him to flee
to safety.
Most of them did but Churchill was captured
as a prisoner of war and sent to Pretoria.
Churchill’s conditions in captivity could
have been worse.
The Boers allowed prisoners to buy cigarettes,
beer, and newspapers after all.
But Churchill hated every moment of it, feeling
the opportunity for glory slipping him by.
One night, with no real plan of how to make
it out of the 300 miles of enemy territory,
he made a daring escape.
A massive manhunt ensued and the fugitive
Churchill was wanted “dead or alive.”
He avoided capture, travelling at night and
drinking water from streams and when he could
go no further, he took a chance by knocking
on a stranger’s door.
On the other side, he knew not whether friend
or foe.
Saved by pure chance or fate, it was an Englishman
who answered.
“I felt like a drowning man pulled out of
the water,” Churchill would recall.
The Englishman was John Howard, a coal mine
manager who hid Churchill in a pitch-black
mine before he could be smuggled to safety...rats
were his only company.
In Britain, the story of an English lord’s
son escaping prison camp and humiliating the
Boers was a boost to the nation.
He became a hero and a celebrity overnight.
Early Years in Parliament
With a hero’s welcome and newfound popularity
Churchill ran for office, and this time in
1900, he was elected as Member of Parliament
in the House of Commons.
This was the start of a 55-year long political
career with the highest of highs and the lowest
of lows.
Churchill once said, "Politics is almost as
exciting as war, and quite as dangerous.
In war you can only be killed once, but in
politics many times."
Churchill was a Conservative (Tory) when he
first stepped into the House of Commons but
he repeatedly clashed with his party on a
number of issues.
Free Trade was crucial in his mind and in
1904, it was his party’s support of tariffs
that made Churchill ‘cross the floor,’
to the opposing Liberal side.
It infuriated his fellow Conservatives but
it proved to be great timing; the Liberals
took control soon after.
As a newfound Liberal, Churchill concerned
himself with social reforms and laid the groundwork
for the post-war ‘welfare state.’
Churchill again “ratted” -- or switched
sides -- back to the Conservative Party in
1925.
The flippant politician was highly criticized
for the moves and he was seen as an untrustworthy
opportunist.
Churchill’s greatest political failure,
the one that nearly ruined his career, came
in 1915.
World War I was at a stalemate along the Western
Front with Allied troops engaged in deadly
trench warfare.
Anxious to end it, Britain’s War Cabinet
authorized a bold military attack, the mastermind
of the 40-year old First Lord of the Admiralty,
Winston Churchill.
The campaign would send troops over 1,000
miles to the east, establishing a second front
to eventually seize Constantinople and take
control of the sea route from Europe to Russia.
The plan involved a naval attack through the
Dardanelles strait, then a land invasion on
the Gallopini peninsula in modern day Turkey.
Lack of intelligence, incompetence, and hesitation
by military commanders created the perfect
storm and the campaign went horribly wrong.
Half of the ships were lost and a bloodbath
on the shores lasted nine months.
In all, 46,000 Allied troops and 65,000 Turkish
lost their lives.
Right or wrong, Churchill bore the brunt of
the failure and it forced his resignation
from politics for a time...Churchill then
returned to the warfront.
The Gallopini campaign haunted Churchill for
decades -- “Remember the Dardanelles,”
was a favorite taunt from political opponents
throughout his career.
A second controversy would plague Churchill
for a decade and send him into political exile,
a period known as the “Wilderness Years.”
In 1929, a debate erupted over self-government
in India, at the time under British rule.
Churchill was no doubt an Imperialist and
was vehemently opposed.
He also had no love for Gandhi; he saw him
as a threat to the British empire and went
so far as to say, "Gandhi should not be released
on the account of a mere threat of fasting,"
and "We should be rid of a bad man and an
enemy of the Empire if he died."
Except for the most right-winged of Conservatives,
Churchill was alone in his position.
Personal Life
Much has been written about Winston Churchill
the statesman, but what was ‘the bulldog’
like at home?
Who was he to his family and friends?
When Clementine Hozier met the 29-year old
Winston in 1904 at a dance, she wasn't impressed.
He didn’t ask her to dance, just stared,
and “never uttered one word and was very
gauche.”
Four years later they would meet again at
a dinner party and this time a romance blossomed.
The couple married in 1908 and would endure
57 years together until Winston’s death
at the age of 90.
Even though Clementine’s politics differed
from Winston’s, she was fiercely supportive
and made standing by her man her number one
priority.
She quietly advised him and was the only person
who could reprimand his behavior.
Clementine once said, “she would have loved
to have been a statesman in her own right
if only she had been born with trousers rather
than petticoats.”
Winston was overbearing and temperamental
at times but he was always transparent in
his love for his wife, proudly boasting to
Roosevelt, “I tell Clemmie everything.”
On occasion, the couple would fight though
-- money was a constant worry for Clementine
who was born into the aristocracy but wound
up penniless in her youth.
Winston overspent, enjoyed gambling, and was
in and out of debt.
During one passionate dispute, Clementine
famously threw a plate of spinach at her husband
(it missed).
And, she never quite forgave him for buying
the family home and money pit Chartwell; doing
so on the sly when she was laid up from giving
birth.
The couple had five children but only four
would survive into adulthood.
Their third child, Marigold, died at the age
of two and a half from septicemia (infection
of the blood) -- a condition modern-day antibiotics
would cure.
Clementine “shrieked in agony, like an animal
in mortal pain,” upon her daughter’s death.
One year later, the Churchill’s fourth child,
Mary, was born.
Winston was delighted to have the nursery
in use again.
Churchill’s duties as statesman often took
him away from home but he was devoted to his
family.
Determined to be different from his own parents
who were distant and cold, whenever he could,
he dotted on his children.
He built them a treehouse at the family home,
and used his skills as a bricklayer, to construct
a little summer house for Mary.
Over 40 years at Chartwell, Churchill proudly
improved the property by his own hands, building
ponds, structures, and bridges.
The Churchill’s had a multitude of pets
-- domestic and exotic.
Churchill was an animal lover his whole life.
As a teen in 1891, he even sold his bicycle
to buy a bulldog named “Dodo.”
At the family home they had both cats and
dogs -- as well as pigs, fish, butterflies,
sheep, horses, and black swans.
There was even a parrot called “Charlie”
who it was rumored Churchill taught to squawk
obscenities against Hitler and the Nazis -- though
this hasn’t been proven and is likely a
myth.
When not enamored with politics and acting
as “savior of his country” Churchill was
writing, painting, playing polo, laying bricks
at the family home, or vacationing with friends
in Monte Carlo or another exotic location.
‘The Darkest Hour’
“We shall fight on the beaches, we shall
fight on the landing grounds, we shall fight
in the fields and in the streets, we shall
fight in the hills; we shall never surrender.”
If it wasn’t for Hitler and the Nazis, Churchill
may never have become Britain’s Prime Minister.
After losing his cabinet position in 1929,
many believed Churchill’s political career
was over.
Even though he was out of politics, he was
not out of the public eye.
He continued to write books, speeches, and
newspaper articles -- and warned of the dangers
of Hitler.
From his home in Kent, his predictions of
the growing Nazi power, and quest for domination
was coming true.
He later wrote in his memoirs, “My warnings
over the last six years had been so numerous,
so detailed, and were now so terribly vindicated,
that no one could gainsay me.”
At the war’s outbreak then Prime Minister
Neville Chamberlain brought Churchill back
into the fray as Britain’s First Lord of
the Admiralty, the same position he held during
the first World War.
Chamberlain had tried, and failed, to strike
a peace deal with Hitler and he showed himself
incapable of turning the rapid tide of fascism.
Chamberlain lost the support of his cabinet
when British troops couldn’t prevent the
occupation of Norway in 1940.
Chamberlain resigned, and Churchill took over
as Prime Minister at the “darkest hour.”
The same day, May 10, Hitler invaded Holland,
Belgium, and the Netherlands.
Churchill was a brilliant orator; thanks to
his mastery of words.
He inspired his countrymen to fight, and some
of his speeches during the early days of the
war are some of the most powerful in the English
language.
Victory was the only option, he never considered
defeat, even when the outcome looked grim.
When France fell to the Nazis, Britain was
alone in its fight.
Churchill knew his island nation could not
win the war alone -- he would need the United
States.
And, when Germany invaded Russia, Churchill
saw an opportunity to forge an unlikely alliance.
Britain came to Stalin’s aid and Churchill
defended the decision during the desperate
time, saying, “No one has been a more consistent
opponent of Communism for the last twenty-five
years.
I will unsay no word I have spoken about it.
But all this fades away before the spectacle
which is now unfolding.
The past, with its crimes, its follies, its
tragedies, flashes away.…
The Russian danger is therefore our danger,
and the danger of the United States, just
as the cause of any Russian fighting for hearth
and house is the cause of free men and free
peoples in every quarter of the globe.”
To forge the big three alliance, Churchill
cultivated a friendship with the American
president, Franklin D. Roosevelt to convince
him to join the war effort.
He invited himself to the White House and
arrived two weeks after the bombing of Pearl
Harbor.
The Prime Minister stayed three weeks, through
Christmas, and well past his welcome in Eleanor
Roosevelt’s eyes.
But, it was critical to solidifying their
alliance and winning over the Americans.
The two bonded over daily lunches and late-night
strategizing — Churchill was known to work
late into the night.
By the time he left, F.D.R.
found he missed his friend and sent a note
to Churchill in London, it read “It is fun
to be in same decade with you.”
With the Americans now in the war, and the
Russians fighting on the side of the Allies,
Hitler’s armies were pushed back and victory
was declared on May 8, 1945 in Europe.
Three months later in the east, Japan surrendered,
marking the end of World War II.
In a surprise the same year, Churchill did
not win re-election.
The End of an Era
Following the war, Churchill continued to
influence world affairs.
He gave his speech on the “iron curtain,”
about the USSR threat and was strongly in
favor of Britain’s independence from the
European Coal and Steel Community, which was
set up after the war to neutralize European
competition for natural resources.
Churchill served as Prime Minister again in
1951 and resigned at the age of 80.
By that time he was in deteriorating health.
Churchill was intent on leaving his mark on
history, not just through clamoring for fame
and power or placing himself at the center
of action.
He would write his own story and solidify
a favorable view to be passed on through the
ages.
At the end of World War II, Churchill wrote
his best-selling series, The Second War World
and won the Nobel Prize in Literature in 1953.
In the same year he was knighted by Queen
Elizabeth II.
In 1965, after suffering a stroke two weeks
earlier, Winston Churchill passed from this
life into the next.
It seemed the whole world felt the loss; and
reporters remarked it was the end of an era.
The Queen saw to it that Churchill’s funeral
was the grandest of any commoner since 1852,
“on a scale befitting his position in history.”
His body lay in state in Westminster Hall
for three days and nights and no fewer than
320,000 people filed past to pay their respects.
Ten years ago, a fifth of all British teenagers
polled believed Churchill to be a fictional
character.
His legend may seem larger-than-life, and
knowing the man, apart from his greatest moment
on the world’s stage, is harder to grasp.
To say he was complex and contradictory is
an understatement.
We know he held himself in the highest regard,
but Churchill also suffered in the depths
of depression — he referred to it as his
“black dog.”
His stubbornness, courage, grit, and brilliance
with words made him indispensable and his
legacy is one that will live on and inspire
the good fight.
And no doubt, Churchill will continue to be
judged and analyzed through the ages for his
failed decisions and unpopular attitudes.
He was a product of the time, with an impossible
job.
“Statesmen are not called upon only to settle
easy questions.
These often settle themselves.
It is where the balance quivers, and the proportions
are veiled in mist, that the opportunity for
world-saving decisions presents itself.”